.
FLORENCE NAVIA
- Il y a fallu vraiment qu'onopé
qui se présente à nous parce que
dans l'état actuel du marché,
on ne voyait pas comment c'était
possible.unununununununununununt
présentée en décembre dernier.
Florence Navia est devenue
propriétaire à Montréal,
contre toute attenlelelelelelels
de son immeuble ont décidé de
se mettre ensemble pour acheter
le triplex qu'ils habitent
dans la PetiOnOnOnOnOnOnOnOnOnOe
Damoclès au-dessus de la tête
en tant que locataire, fait
qu'on était comme : tant qu'à
ça, on
on paie plus cher de frais
d'intérêt qu'on payait de loyer.
- La hausse des taux
hypothécaires, l'inflationèèèèès
élevé ont finalement eu raison
de la flambée immobilière connue
pendant la pandémie.ouououououor
résiden. et comm. Royal Lepage
- On sent qu'on approche d'un
marché qui va être plus
les acquéreurs depuis deux ans
et puis on retourne
à la réalité.
- Entre décembre 2021 et 2022,
à Toronto de 4,6 %, de 3,5 %
à Vancouver 3 3 3,3 % à Halifax
et de 2,7 % à Ottawa.
Les march
et de Calgary ont pour leur part
connu des hausses.
avaient cru aussi plus
rapidement que ceux de Montréal,
dans l'explosion du marché.
si on veut, va être un peu plus
présent dans ces marchés-là.
- Un retour qui n'effacera pas
pendant la pandémie et ce même
si en 20yayayayal Lepage prévoit
encore une légère baisse
des prix soit 1 % globaÉROUX, ée
en chef de la BDC
- Les taux d'intérêt demeurent
élevés, l'économie va ralentir,
à ce que les prix dégringolent
de façon importante parce qu'il
y a des facteurs qui supportent
le mar
- Des facteurs comme
l'immigration, le niveau
d'emploi élevé et la rareté
- Les inventaires soeeeee
faibles et ça, ça aide g g g g d
dam des acheteurs. Je sais que
les acheteurs disent :
"J'aimerais ça qu'il y ait plusn
temps, les maisons ne partent
plus en feu, mais l'inventaire
n'est pas très gros.
- Ça fait vraimfifififififififi.
- Surtout pour les quartiers
centraux comme ceux
qui intéressent Florence.
- On est'é'é'é'é'é'é'é'é'é'é'é'.
- Ici Jacaudrey Charbonneau,
Radio-Canada, Montréa